influential Muslim scholar Yusuf
al-khadawi has died at the age of 96.
the guitar-based cleric was a founding
member of the international Union of
Muslim Scholars he was sentenced to
death in absentee in his native Egypt in
2015 a military Court there accused him
and several others of involvement in the
prison break of former president
Muhammad Morsi he'd written 170 books
and Publications on Islamic
jurisprudence of Jamal al-shah yal joins
us live from Istanbul now and can you
tell us more about the Legacy that he
leaves behind
well as you mentioned
we authored more than 120 books and more
than 50 60 other Publications that spoke
to a large section of the global Muslim
Community he was probably the most
internationalized Muslim scholar that
Islam had in modern days probably the
single most influential in that he
didn't limit his teachings to a specific
section of Islam so he wasn't just a
theologian he also spoke about modern
day issues everything from the
permissible permissibility of
relationships to
elections and democracy to social
justice issues in fact one of his most
significant trips happened many years
ago when he was headed a delegation of
Scholars to at the time what was the
Taliban held Afghanistan to convince
them not to destroy Buddhist statues
there in his uh teachings the need to
respect diversity and pluralism in
religion he founded the European Council
on fatwa which dealt with providing
religious advice for the large the
millions of Muslims living in Europe and
particularly on issues like Palestine
and other Justice causes he was
unwavering in his teachings and his
beliefs there as well
and Jamal he was a controversial figure
too wasn't he
foreign
for example when it came to Palestine he
uh believed that there was a right for
the Palestinians to resist uh an illegal
military occupation when it came to the
Arab Spring he uh was vehement in his
support for the people to rise up
against oppressive regimes in Egypt in
Syria in Yemen and other places and that
earned him the wrath of many of the
military uh regimes and uh despotic
regimes in the region which either as we
was in the case of Egypt sentenced him
to death or uh made him persona nagrata
for example in the United Arab Emirates
and other places but you know from as
far east as Indonesia where when he
would go he would be met with hundreds
of thousands of people
to listen to his sermons to all the way
west to the United States where his
teachings influenced a lot of
organizations and mosques there he he
did have a very far reach and obviously
Islam different to Christianity and that
Christianity has the pope and has
specific figures in the absence of that
within the Muslim world he was one of
the closest to Sunni Islam's most
significant figures and in fact in his
foundation of the International
Coalition of or International Council of
Muslim Scholars which included also Shia
representatives and other
sects within Islam he did have quite
significant success in bridging some of
the uh gaps between the different sets
of the Muslim world so in his passing
obviously it will be felt by millions of
Muslims around the world it will also
obviously have a political impact in
that again he influenced a lot of the
political movements within the Muslim
world but he does leave behind him more
than 120 books and a legacy which will
uh most definitely outlive him
thank you very much that's Jamal
al-shellal for us in Istanbul
well let's bring in Ibrahim Salah
al-name he is Chairman of Doha
International Center for Interfaith
dialogue he is also under Secretary of
the Ministry of Education in higher
education in the state of Qatar he joins
us from Doha thank you so much for being
on this NewsHour
um first of all what made kadawi such a
significant Muslim scholar what do you
think his legacy will be
yeah well first of all I'd like to you
know to share with what Jamal said
earlier with our deepest condolences and
sorrow to the whole world the Islamic
world to the Arab world Anthony people
of Qatar for the big loss of uh
yes he he was a moderate a great
scholar that he really
was kind
to to you know to to look into the
relation among the followers of
different faiths especially Islam and
Christianity who work so high so close
to to many of the uh representatives of
the different faiths to bring together
um the Harmony and to really uh
put down the the the the the the this
hate speeches that went in some time
among the different faiths so he was a
great scholar he was my my teacher when
I was at Qatar University he he led a
center of a harabawi center for moderate
a renewable are you and renewal in in
since 2008 he was really will be missed
very highly here in Qatar and around the
world what were some of his key
religious rulings or fatwas
in fact here he was you know as as you
mentioned and Jamal mentioned earlier
that he had published uh so many books
among them as the uh really great books
on Halal Haram and Islam the
the Halal
so this kind of book that really many
many uh people around the world follow
what was the uh acceptable and or lawful
lovable and and the uh in Islam and the
the
the things are not really allowed in
Islam so the he his his Publications are
very important in so many uh scholars in
the in the in the interface Arena he he
was the first to establish with among
scholars in qataria uh the first
Interfaith dialogue in Qatar in 2003
after the 911 uh
incident when he was really against what
happened and and that uh uh incident in
New York and really after that the
Conference was held in Qatar here on
Islam how did he strike a balance
between uh sticking to authentic
scripture yet providing answers to
modern day challenges
is as I said as I mentioned earlier he's
a really moderate he looked into uh his
all all the issues and and very moderate
way in his way and look at cares about
tolerance cares about Building Bridges
between uh different religions and uh
try to you know in his books and his
teachings and in the throughout his
Publications to really bring together
peaceful uh uh coexistence between
different religions and he really
applies the Islamic teachings in this
very very well
and politically speaking what made him
loved by many people yet hated by some
governments
well I uh and as I think Jamal mentioned
that earlier that he's really he was he
was against a suppression against the
oppression against the uh any kind of
really uh
against any anything related to speech
he he wanted and he he really supported
all the all the
movements Democratic movements around
the world that really give the the the
people the chance really to be to
express themselves and to really uh
govern themselves so he was against the
oppression and therefore he was being
hated by some governments but but he
been left throughout the world
ibrahimi thank you so much for your time
uh this afternoon